einige haben gesagt das ist ja
sensationell mit eurem 200.000
abonnenten klick zum youtuber treffen in
berlin aber ich kann am 21 10 10 nicht
kommen und da haben uns überlegt auch
die sollen was davon haben von diesem
sensationellen ereignis und auch was
gewinnen können und zwar unser hammer
mäßiges youtube buch in dem alles
drinsteht was man minimum wissen muss um
auf youtube erfolgreich zu werden mit
den basis kenntnissen über das drehen
von videos bis hin zu ein paar kleinen
geheimtipps wie man schneller partner
wird und so weiter und so fort was
müsste dafür tun eine mail schreiben an
contest at manfrotto punkt.de und
folgende frage beantworten aus welchem
land kommt manfrotto denn eigentlich
sammer süden ist nicht ganz falsch und
er sollte nicht nur die antwort indem er
ein schreiben sondern auch namen und
adresse natürlich in diesem fall das
stichwort sollte noch clixoom und buch
sein dann könnte er daran teilnehmen und
dieses buch gewinnen ich drück die
daumen und freue mich auf alle die doch
sich irgendwie loseisen können und nach
berlin kommen am 21 10 16 uhr im sony
center das ist am potsdamer platz im
manfrotto interactive foto lab bleibt
dran bis dann